france first deployed some 5 000 troops
to northern mali in 2013
amid worsening violence from armed
groups
now as most french troops prepare to
leave mali's prime minister told the u.n
general assembly his country feels
abandoned and needs to look elsewhere
for help with its security the nouvelle
situation near the fender barkan the new
situation resulting from the end of
operation barcane puts mali before a
fade accompli
abandoning us mid-flight to a certain
extent and it leads us to explore
pathways and means to better ensure our
security autonomously or with other
partners so as to fill the gap which
will certainly result from the
withdrawal of barcane in the north of
the country
and with anti-western sentiment on the
rise in mali a shift is emerging away
from france towards russia its foreign
minister sergey lavrov confirmed mali
had requested the assistance of a
russian military contractor but didn't
mention the wagner group by name
he said it had nothing to do with his
government
they are combating terrorism
incidentally
and they've turned to a private military
company from russia in connection with
the fact that as i understand france
wants to significantly draw down its
military component which was present
there and as everyone understood should
have been combating terrorists who
established a presence in qidel but they
didn't manage to do that
from libya to the central african
republic the west has accused wagner of
meddling in conflict zones on moscow's
behalf an allegation russia denies
but the european union has warned such a
move in mali would cross a red line and
threaten relations with the west african
nation
these latest maneuvers add to the
tensions in a country where the united
nations has more than 13 thousand
peacekeepers and the security council
has been pushing for elections since the
military took over in a coup last year
kristen salumi al jazeera the united
nations